(bubbly music)
- Hey Mia, have you seen my phone?
- No. Oh I did see one
in the women's bathroom.
- Oh yay!
- Yes I'd love a glass
of the pinot grigio.
- [Waitress] Great, I'm just
going to need to see your ID.
- Sure.
- Oh my God.
- Um.
- You know I changed wallets.
I think I left it in my other wallet.
- [Woman] Hey can
anybody bring me a towel?
Is anybody home?
- We're like really excited to have you.
Hey Michelle!
This is our new intern, Stacey.
- Hi, nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
- Thank you so much, I gotta go.
- Wait, what was her name?
- Seriously?
- Hey, Mia do you have a
phone charger I can borrow?
Thank you so much.
I'll get it right back,
just need it for 10 minutes.
Oh yay that's tonight.
That's tonight?
Oh God, no.
Are you kidding me?
Dammit!
Oh no.
Did I leave the stove on?
Oh no it says on Facebook that
it's Mia's birthday today.
- Shoot! No I told her I'd take her
to Disneyland for her birthday.
- I really wanted to get her something
cause she got me Beyonce
tickets for my birthday.
- I didn't get her a Christmas present.
- Hey guys!
- Hi!
Happy birthday!
- Thank you!
- We got you this snake.
- From both of us.
- Thank you!
- Since you love Britney Spears.
- I love it.
- Yay.
(bubbly music)